jour de gloire pour le chocolat et oui
pas qu'autant que noël de fête
chrétienne ne s'accompagne de douceur
païenne et fondante un petit point
d'histoire en passant on connait le
chocolat en france depuis le 17e siècle
mais c'est seulement au siècle dernier
que les confiseurs ont découvert le
moulage et de l'avis des professionnels
parmi toutes les délicieuses chose à
croquer qui livre notre gourmandise et
bien ce sont les cocottes qui ont la
préférence des petits d'ailleurs des
grands aussi alors charles ortega et
suzanne de morlhon qui ont un fois toute
épreuve et biens sont allés prendre la
mesure exacte de ce marché exceptionnel
savez vous combien de temps il a fallu
pour réaliser ce superbe jeannot lapin
et ses petites cocottes quatre heures
durant quatre heures nous avons suivi
leurs élaborations délicate
le travail du chocolat est tout un art
le chocolat est un mélange de trois
éléments la pâte de cacao
le beurre de cacao qu'il sut lorsqu'on
fait fondre le chocolat brut au bain
marie
le beurre de cacao se sépare de la pâte
est fait en dosant ces deux éléments
faux n'obtient chocolat plus ou moins
corsé plus ou moins amère il faut
ensuite le travail et on le table on le
compte jusqu'à ce que l'on est obtenue
la température et la consistance idéal
et pour éviter toute anomalie due à des
bulles par exemple on passe toutes les
couches hop en dessous et à la mise au
point du chocolat c'est quelque chose de
très facile et aussi de très compliqué
il faut tout d'abord fondant chocolat de
manière à ce qu'il ait la consistance
voulue pour pouvoir la travailler
ensuite le refroidir pour l'amener à la
température voulue pour qu'il soit
brillant
lorsqu'on va des moules et la pièce le
consommateur progressivement
appréciée de plus en plus le chocolat
noir est légèrement corsé pour ne pas
dire à mr peintre d'art à sa manière le
chocolatier commence par les éléments
décoratifs au chocolat noir puis il
achève avec le chocolat blanc chocolat
blanc est obtenue uniquement par du
beurre de cacao et du sucre reste à
passer la première couche de couverture
toujours au pinceau on laisse le
chocolat se prendre puis on recommence 1
6 4 6 ou une fois jusqu'à ce qu'il
obtienne la consistance nécessaire le
prestige du chocolat suisse c'est un
mythe ou une réalité pour un
professionnel c'est un mythe
nous pensons faire des chocolats haut
niveau artisanal qui sont d'une qualité
au moins égale à ses chocolats suisses
et au niveau du chocolat alors cette
année comment ça se présente à pâques au
bien je pense que ça se présente comme
chaque année les gens les grands-mères
aime beaucoup offrir un petit cadeau à
leurs petits-enfants et à leurs familles
on assiste à un phénomène
nous connaissions déjà mais qui se
développe de plus en plus c'est le
l'expédition de chocolats pour pâques
les chocolats de pâques vivent leurs
derniers jours dans les vitrines les
moulages ont commencé depuis trois
semaines et les ventes n'excéderont
guerre les lendemains du 1er avril
et même si l'air faste des rameaux garni
de chocolat est quasi agolli la
tradition reste vivace au sein des
familles